bueno pues españa es una de las 10
monarquías parlamentarias de europa y
como no podía ser de otra manera fue la
casa de su majestad el rey de españa la
primera en reaccionar
oficialmente tras la muerte o el anuncio
de la muerte de isabel segunda lo hizo a
través de un telegrama mostrando el
nombre del pueblo español y del gobierno
español su más sentido pésame al pueblo
británico y a la familia de la reina
isabel e 2ª felipe sexto destacó en su
telegrama el sentido del deber de la
monarca su compromiso y toda una vida
dedicada al servicio del pueblo que
quedará según palabras del monarca
español como un sólido y valioso legado
para las generaciones futuras un
telegrama que finalizó dice afirmando
que la echarán mucho de menos y es que
recordemos que ambas familias reales la
española y la británica tienen
parentesco están relacionadas porque
ambas descienden por un lado de la reina
victoria de inglaterra y por otro del
cristian noveno de dinamarca de ahí la
cercanía entre el rey felipe sexto y
toda la casa real española y la casa
real británica por su parte el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez también ha enviado un mensaje de
condolencias por la muerte de la reina
isabel segunda a través de su cuenta de
twitter a quien ha destacado como una
figura de relevancia mundial
testigo y autora de la historia
británica y europea el gobierno regional
de madrid por su parte ha decretado tres
días de luto en los que las banderas de
los edificios públicos ondearán a media
asta y un dato curioso y es que la reina
isabel segunda hizo su primera y única
visita de estado a españa en
1988 bastante tardía
porque había desavenencias entre ambas
monarquías sobre todo a raíz de
la decisión del príncipe el entonces
príncipe carlos y la princesa daiana de
salir de gibraltar para su luna de miel
un territorio que está en la península
ibérica' pero que ha sido disputado
entre ambas naciones
precisamente y curiosamente aunque la
primera visita de estado fue en 1988 a
españa no fue la primera vez que la
monarca isabel segunda quiso suelo
ibérico puesto que visitó gibraltar en
1954 este ha sido quizás el único punto
de desavenencias entre ambas familias
reales la española y la británica